[Música]
Rusia acusa a Ucrania de bloquear el
ingreso del organismo Internacional de
la energía atómica azapurilla para
revisar Cómo quedó la planta nuclear más
grande de Europa luego de los bombardeos
de los que las partes se culpan
mutuamente kiev responde que esto es un
total despropósito y que quiere que el
organismo vaya a la central
los presidentes de Colombia y de chile
Gustavo Petro y Gabriel borich se
reunieron en Bogotá allí discutieron
sobre la paz Cómo renovar las alianzas
latinoamericanas y cooperar en temas
como la migración la lucha contra el
crimen organizado y las energías limpias
un tercer tanque de combustible se
incendió en la provincia cubana de
matanzas el fuego que comenzó el viernes
se propagó en la noche del domingo y hoy
la presidencia del país afirma que la
infraestructura colapsó
Bienvenidos a la actualidad
internacional aquí en France 24 yo soy
María Clara calle Gracias por estar con
nosotros
empezamos las noticias Como todos los
octavos días del mes Recordando el
secuestro del periodista francés Olivier
este 8 de agosto de 2012 de 2022 se
cumplen 16 meses desde que lo raptaron
en nombre de la libertad de prensa en
apoyo a su familia y a sus personas más
cercanas en France 24 le seguimos
dedicando nuestros pensamientos hasta
que lo liberen
y continuamos con la actualidad de la
guerra en Ucrania
Moscú y kiev se acusan mutuamente de no
permitir el ingreso del organismo
Internacional de la energía atómica a
saporiya esto para revisar Cómo quedó la
planta nuclear después de los bombardeos
de este fin de semana además las
autoridades de la región instaladas por
los rusos firmaron un decreto que prevé
un referendo para unirse a Moscú un
proyecto similar estaba dando en la
controlada jerson desde julio donde el
gobierno prorruso creó comisiones
electorales para la para la votación de
adhesión analizaremos el tema con aribel
Contreras ella es analista de asuntos
globales y está en Ciudad de México
señora Contreras un placer volver a
hablar con usted primero cuéntenos de la
planta nuclear Porque es importante que
el oída visite la planta y cuál es el
riesgo para Ucrania y para Europa de que
sigan los combates alrededor
un gusto saludarte María claria María
Clara y me parece importante Resaltar
que este organismo multilateral se
encarga entre muchas otras funciones
Pues de hacer toda una revisión para
poder ver los daños ocasionados por este
bombardeo Más allá de si es de un lado o
del otro lado hay riesgos por todo lo
que esto implica a las comunidades
cercanas de saporiya Entonces estamos
viendo que el hecho de que no se permita
una revisión técnica que nada tiene que
ver con la parte política ni ni de la
guerra es importante que se haga y si no
se permite pues entonces no se van a
poder evaluar los daños y las
consecuencias estamos viendo ahorita que
se está hablando de esta planta nuclear
pero ya en el pasado en la coyuntura de
esta guerra ya hemos visto los ataques y
los bombardeos a otras plantas nucleares
María claro Entonces estos son muy malas
noticias y y como tan son también malas
noticias el tema de del referéndum no O
sea ahorita la coyuntura actual María
Clara es la Tormenta perfecta para
Vladimir Putin de lo que se está
suscitando en Taiwán donde todo el foco
de atención internacional está ahorita
esta isla y no en lo que está sucediendo
que nos ocupa desde hace meses atrás en
Ucrania y precisamente a propósito de
estos referendos en saprilla y en gerson
que ustedes menciona ya Rusia había
adelantado una estrategia similar en
crimea el territorio que se anexaron en
2014 con qué nivel de coacción se
realizan estos procesos que ya son
costumbre para Rusia
totalmente y que parece que esta
estrategia de del año 2014 lo quiere
replicar ahora hablar y mi Putin pero me
parece que la circunstancias han
cambiado el mundo ha cambiado y yo creo
que la población y de crimea en ese
momento que hiciera totalmente prosa no
está al 100% tan alineada ahora en estas
zonas de dejar son o de esa polilla como
como lo fueron en crimea entonces este
tema de este manipuleo para cobijar y
decir que es un referéndum que surge
desde la población Por supuesto que no
es así la población lo que no quiere es
tener el verdugo en casa y mucho menos
que haya una anexación Entonces estamos
viendo que ahorita la estrategia de
Rusia es intentar venderles lo mismo que
pasó en el año 2014 pero el resultado no
puede ser el mismo y me parece que lejos
de avanzar hacia un proceso de paz esto
lo único que está sumando es encender
más ya de la guerra y fragmentar mucho
la parte de la sociedad Ariel Gracias
por estar con nosotros
encantada y muy buenas tardes un gusto
estar aquí en trans 24 cambiamos de
noticia luego de una semana de bloqueos
por parte de Israel las autoridades de
este país comenzaron a reabrir
parcialmente los cruces hacia la
frontera de gaza los israelíes permiten
por ahora únicamente los suministros de
necesidades humanitarias y así llegaron
los primeros camiones de combustibles y
se reinició la única planta energética
del enclave todo esto es un efecto de La
tregua que pactaron Israel y la yihada
islámica Palestina desde este domingo
con la mediación de Egipto según el
Ministerio de sanidad palestino el
enfrentamiento de tres días deja 44
fallecidos incluidos 15 niños
es el primer día de tregua Después de
tres días de hostilidades la yihadi
islámica Palestina e Israel cesaron sus
ataques en una negociación mediada por
Egipto según el ejército israelí el
último ataque se registró media hora
antes de la medianoche del domingo
Naciones Unidas y Egipto pidieron
respetar el alto el fuego pero el grupo
yihadista aseguró que Se reserva el
derecho a responder cualquier nueva
agresión el enemigo pretendía acabar con
la llegada islámica pero no lo hicimos
por el contrario logramos algo y
forzamos las condiciones por las que
comenzamos la batalla con el enemigo
Israel Se comprometió a liberar a
nuestros prisioneros
con un regreso lento a la normalidad los
habitantes en gaza agradecieron por un
amanecer sin bombardeos mientras entre
escombros se contabiliza el saldo de
muertos y heridos que dejó el
enfrentamiento más mortífero desde la
guerra de 11 días del año pasado
recibimos la noticia del alto el fuego
con alegría y felicidad volvimos nuestro
trabajo no queríamos más derramamiento
de sangre y gracias a Dios volvimos a
nuestro trabajo y abrimos las puertas de
nuestras tiendas
la frontera entre Israel y la franja de
gaza esta nuevamente abierta tras un
cierre de casi una semana que dejó la
única central eléctrica del enclave
palestino sin suministros de combustible
30 camiones en este momento es una
cantidad suficiente y en los próximos
días esperamos aproximadamente el mismo
número de vehículos para llenar el vacío
el conflicto inició con un ataque
preventivo de Israel en el que murieron
los principales líderes de la yihadi
islámica considerados terroristas por la
nación judía Estados Unidos y la Unión
Europea en la última semana 40 miembros
del grupo islamista han sido detenidos
por las fuerzas israelíes en sus
Jordania el presidente de Estados Unidos
Joe biden expresó preocupación después
de que china anunciara nuevos ejercicios
militares cerca de Taiwán a pesar de que
el domingo había acabado sus maniobras
alrededor de las defensas de taipei
Taiwán reportó que 21 aviones chinos
entraron en su zona de defensa aérea de
este lunes
por quinto día consecutivo los aviones
de combate y Los buques de guerra chinos
siguen en acción Beijing decidió ampliar
su entrenamiento militar a lo largo de
Taiwán
es territorio de China china lleva a
cabo ejercicios militares normales en
las aguas que rodean su propio
territorio es abierto transparente y
profesional los departamentos chinos
pertinentes también han emitido anuncios
de manera oportuna Esto está en línea
con la ley nacional el derecho
internacional y la práctica
internacional
estas maniobras chinas que comenzaron
tras la visita de Nancy pelosia Taiwán
debían terminar el domingo
a pesar de La amenaza todo avanza con
normalidad en las calles de taipei
contrario a las decisiones de las
autoridades de La Isla que acaban de
anunciar sus propios ejercicios
militares a partir del martes los
aviones y barcos chinos nunca han
entrado en nuestro espacio aéreo ni en
nuestras aguas territoriales nuestros
militares desplegarán aviones y barcos
para responder a las posiciones enemigas
sin embargo taipei dice que las
maniobras estaban previstas desde hace
mucho tiempo La Isla democrática y
Autónoma vive bajo la constante amenaza
de una invasión por parte de China
Beijing considera su vecino como parte
de su territorio y su objetivo es
recuperarla por la fuerza de ser
necesario
los mandatarios de izquierda Gustavo
Petro y Gabriel borich se reunieron hoy
en la casa de nariño el Palacio
presidencial de Colombia un día después
de que Pedro asumiera el mando al
término de la primera reunión que
sostienen como presidentes el líder
chileno enfatizó que es importante
profundizar en la cooperación para
combatir al crimen organizado otro de
los temas que discutieron fue como
trabajar conjuntamente en cuanto a la
migración de haitianos y venezolanos ya
que chile y Colombia son uno de los
mayores países receptores también
quieren fortalecer la comunidad de
Estados latinoamericanos y caribeños la
celac y hacer alianzas para energías
limpias otro eje del encuentro fueron
los diálogos de paz con la guerrilla del
eln que fueron suspendidos durante el
gobierno de Iván Duque y de los que
chile es garante en ese marco hemos
hablado de el desafiante proceso de paz
que ha llevado adelante Colombia
y todos los aprendizajes que de este
proceso Hay que sacar
como chile
desde
el 2016 hemos sido Incluso un poco antes
país garante de este proceso hemos
manifestado toda nuestra disposición a
seguir colaborando los términos que el
gobierno colombiano estime que son más
útiles a su causa y el segundo tema que
abordó ese gobierno fue el diálogo con
el Ln que no llegó a fructificar fue
interrumpido por el gobierno que siguió
en ese punto es que nosotros arrancamos
primero reconocemos los protocolos que
se llamaron así de carácter diplomático
de carácter internacional
revitalizar los protocolos reconocerlos
significa que
y le pedimos a los países que en ese
momento fueron garantes que sigan siendo
garantes pueden haber otros
aumentan los incendios en el
almacenamiento de combustible en la
provincia cubana de matanzas hoy colapso
el tercero de 8 tanques de petróleo
luego de que las llamas iniciaron el
pasado viernes todos los accidentes han
dejado un muerto y 125 heridos Rodrigo
sedano nos cuenta
se cumplió el peor de los pronósticos en
Cuba un tercer tanque de combustible se
incendió en el puerto de matanzas en el
occidente de La Isla esto luego que el
viernes un rayo incendiera un primer
tanque del que es el mayor depósito de
combustible de Cuba el incendio que
había en el segundo tanque comprometió
Entonces el tercer tanque que ahora está
incendiado de la manera que se había
visto anteriormente funcionando como un
pebetero limpio como una como un fogón
el domingo en la noche un segundo tanque
se vio también envuelto en llamas ahora
los vertidos de esta nueva explosión ha
reavivado el fuego de los dos depósitos
anteriores
con tres tanques encendidos Porque
además volvió este combustible en el uno
lo funciona entonces también como como
otras otras formas que estás ahí en de
grandes dimensiones por supuesto este
incendio ahonda en un problema de
escasez de combustible que vive Cuba el
gobernador de la región y el propio
presidente Miguel Díaz canel reconocen
que supondrá un problema a largo plazo
lo que hay que seguir comprando y
dedicándole en poco financiamiento que
tenemos para garantizar a nuestro pueblo
la mínima energía que eso sí es un
problema que tenemos hoy y que él como
se dijo para nuestro presidente no es un
problema a corto plazo a las labores de
extinción se sumaron el domingo
efectivos llegados desde México y
Venezuela por el momento el incendio se
ha cobrado la vida de un bombero y ha
dejado al menos 16 desaparecidos y 125
heridos todo ello en medio de un déficit
energético que organismos oficiales
cifran en un 35% para este lunes cadena
perpetua es la sentencia que impuso una
jueza de estadounidense contra Travis
mcmichael Este era hombre blanco fue
condenado por delitos de odio en el
asesinato de amor albury una
afroamericano al que le dispararon en
2020 mientras corría en un vecindario
mayoritariamente blanco de Georgia Mike
Michael de 36 años Fue el primero de los
tres hombres blancos condenados en
febrero
se espera que su padre gregory mcmichael
y su vecino William rody Bryan también
se han sentenciados hoy el asesinato de
alberry ha sido uno de los más
reconocidos en las manifestaciones
antirracistas Y es que los culpables lo
persiguieron en una camioneta y le
dispararon a quemarropa cuando él estaba
trotando
Irán está evaluando la propuesta de
texto final que le presentó la Unión
Europea para revivir el acuerdo nuclear
de 2015 esto ocurre Después de cinco
días de conversaciones indirectas en
Viena Austria entre las delegaciones de
Estados Unidos y el gobierno persa hoy
la agencia Estatal de noticias iraní la
inra anunció que el equipo de
negociadores regresará a Teherán y
examinará el texto por su parte del
bloque de los 27 confirmó que ya envió
la propuesta a los iraníes el acuerdo
original limita la producción nuclear
del gobierno persa A cambio de qué
occidente le retire las sanciones
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con frases
[Música]